My kids aren't big snackers,
but today they requested some cheeses
after seeing them at the store the other day,
so I decided to just make them some.
These are super simple and quick to make,
so I started off by shredding some cheddar cheese,
combining that in my stand mixer with some salt and butter.
Then mix mix it all until it's pretty much combined
before adding in some flour and some really cold water.
Once that all comes together,
I into a disc and spread it on some plastic wrap
before popping it in the fridge for about an hour and a half.
After it's chilled I pull it back out.
Usually I cut it in half
so it's easier to handle for using my rolling pin
to get it as thin as I can,
and then slice in whatever shape I want.
Usually it's tiny rectangles or squares.
Place those on a Parchment line baking tray
before using the end of a chopstick to put a small hole in the middle
so they resemble Cheez its.
After I've done that with all of them,
I pop them in the oven for about 10 minutes,
let them cool, and then place them in my glass jar.
That's how I usually store them,
but my kids had all of these in one sitting.